but the United States is running  concentration camps on our southern  border and that is exactly what they are  they are concentration camps and if that  doesn't bother you I don't I got I like  we can have okay whatever I want to talk  to the people that are concerned enough  with humanity to say that we should not  that never again mean something and that  the fact that concentration camps are  now in institutionalized practice in the  home of the free is extraordinarily  disturbing and we need to do something  about it this week  children immigrant children were moved  to the same internment camps where the  Japanese were held in in the early in  the earlier 20th century